this is a production of Cornell
University
oh hi everyone you can hear me now right
okay I'm raxa tapa in Virginia Moore lab
and working on breeding for low
temperature tolerance in cover crops
so
can you so what are cover crops I think
most of you have some idea on the cover
crops but I wanted to give some brief uh
intro so
sorry so the cover crops are the crops
that are not harvested for fruits or
other products but rather grown to
provide several environmental benefits
for maintaining Environmental Quality
and agriculture sustainability
and you can grow proper crops in several
time uh um any time of the year but in
my study we are focusing on the winter
cover crops
so the Tom cover crop is not new it's um
it went in Pagan literature around uh
1960 which you can see here in the
figure and then it suddenly dropped down
uh any guesses from the students where I
dropped down
uh well uh because people use cover crop
at that time mainly for wheat separation
and uh
arrival of the uh pesticides
um cause it to drop down but and now
there is a increase in interest again so
you can see here sorry
and you can see here uh in the figure in
um there was 10 million Acres planted
with cover crops which was increased by
50 to uh 15 million acres in 2017 which
is um
which was still this 5.1 percent of the
total harvested car plant so the
Cooperative cover corbination is still
low but it's increasing
so why there is increasing interest in
cover crops so because we get several
benefits from them uh like uh increase
in soil uh water infiltration uh
reduction in the soil compaction
increase in number of the beneficial
organisms like Aur domes or mycorrhizal
fungi increase the number of the
beneficial insects a reduction in soil
erosion through the rent for
Etc
uh there are many problems in uh the
growing cover crops because they have
not been bred for and winter survival is
one of the main problem in Winter cover
crops limiting the uh absence for winter
cover crops and there are several
factors that affect the winter survival
this location where you grow the
temperature and the climatic condition
their environmental conditions such as
the snow accumulation and management
practices such as
um like planting date and species and
the cultivar you choose
for my study we are focusing on several
approaches for increasing the winter
survival uh one of my afros is National
cover crop trial to identify genotype by
environment interaction
and to identify the uh main
environmental parameters that are
um driving the uh Winter survival and
also providing some local recommendation
um
so uh for this study uh this is today
was conducted in 2016 to 2018 and we had
19 locations uh
um sorry
where did it go
sorry sorry for that and so
um there were 19 locations and uh these
are all Planet material Center uh sites
uh
and we had eight species right Clover
crimson clover hairy weights winter pea
Blanca Clover daikon radius uh uh cereal
rye and black coat and for all of the
suspices we had around eight cultivars
and uh I've been doing a license for
this I'm close to getting it done I'm
not done yet so
so my second approach is
um genotype by environment by management
study and we are looking at the effect
of planting the genotype and cropping
system and the winter survival of the
winter pea
so for this study my first factor is
planting date usually for most of the uh
annual cover crops if you plant early
then it's better because like you can
see in the
sorry I'm not used to this sorry yeah
uh
um so if so if you plan early so you'll
get like more cover like you can see in
the figure it's I got it from the mirsky
it's all um
um it all study so but for winter P if
you plan it early then it transitions
from Rosati to Upright growth heavy
leading to reduced Winter survival the
other factor I am dealing with is the
cropping system
um so it's monoculture versus mixer
generally uh if you grow the cover crops
in the mixer you get more
um benefits
um but if you look at the two plants
growing together there is a more
competition between them
um but if you grow uh um if you if you
grow a radium cover crop like winter pea
with the
cereals then it increases the winter
survival after
um of the legumes like winter pea and
the other Factor I'm looking is um the
looking at the uh Precision of the Drone
against visual estimation for uh winter
survival and uh predicting early
prediction of the final biomass or
performance for Farmers so that they can
predict early and just decide whether to
keep the crop or discarded
uh so for this uh study I have three
locations in New York North Dakota and
Minnesota I have four planting dates uh
starting late August and planting in
every two weeks interval and I have four
cultivars and I have two cropping system
monoculture versus biculture uh which is
um we have mixer plus only in the New
York and my drone study is also only in
the New York
and I have some primary uh preliminary
results from the first year uh this is
uh the biomass in New York
um I use a mixed model
and uh accounted from for some special
variation uh and uh if you look at the
figure the different color represent the
uh different planting dates and uh you
can see uh that's Winter survival sorry
the biomass final biomass was greater
for planting day two and three uh
there was a similar trend for winter
survival in Minnesota like you can see
for planting the two and three there was
a higher winter survival except for the
wire winter which had the uh higher
Winter survival at planting date four
um so there is uh there is like
interaction going on for the uh cultivar
by planting date and uh one thing I
wanted you to see is that for all this
uh all these uh combinations the winter
survival was not so high uh the maximum
was uh 70 here
um for the Blaze and in our North Dakota
site the average winter survival was
below nine below 20 percent so and these
are the most common cultivars that are
grown uh now so um that's all we have uh
we're doing uh we will have our another
approach uh genome wide Association is
study for low temperature tolerance in
Winter peas
um we want to find a new genetic
variation uh so that they um
uh so that we can uh so it would help us
to uh develop a new cultivar that would
be able to survive in the northern
regions
so for this study I'm planning to use
USDA single plant plus collection plus
other uh some other USDA and cover crop
breeding Network lines
um and user growth chamber which is
supposed to arrive soon uh and uh
planning to so this USDA single plant
first collection uh was um already
genotype but I will be genotype the
genotype the rest of the authorizations
and uh I'm planning to use uh I only
kiss is one of the main methods to
detect the uh cold damage
so
um
moving forward our another approaches
recurring selection for low temperature
germination and figure in cereal right
uh so um for most of the common Summer
cast club uh they're harvested late in
the fall and uh so it leads to
um small planting window for a cereal
ride like you can plant like uh like
around October and it decreases the uh
like amount of cover and overall
benefits from the cereal Rye so we want
to conduct the study so that we can
identify uh new assistance that can fit
uh
um so that that can have good
um good germination and figure even when
you plant late and feel better fit in
the current crop rotation practice
so for this study I'm planning to use uh
half safe families from our nursery and
I'm planning to do recurrent selection
um moving I want to move forward the
generation in the field and in the uh
Greenhouse uh and do my final tile with
two generations in 2024
so uh uh this was this is my brief uh a
role study I want to thank my community
members Dr Moore and everyone in my
committee uh cover crop reading network
members everyone in the more lab and
cover crop reading Network our
collaborators my funding uh and everyone
who is here to listen to me thank you
sorry
yeah I'm open to questions
I'm sorry
I'm treating like the spring with these
Perfect YouTube click to date when you
score internet survival
oh yes okay cool yeah because I'm
curious is
certain since you have four different
kind of crops to certain ones depending
on how the winner go parts or how they
survived in the winter like I'll repeat
each other at different grades uh uh or
not compete each other but you know
maybe grow a different race depending on
the overwintering of the Year okay if I
understood correctly so you said that is
the if I see different pattern for
different cultivars yeah yeah uh yes so
of course like some of them have like
high figures some of them are like tall
type and they have higher biomass and uh
like uh some like I have monoculture
versus mixer in mixer yeah I'm seeing
like less damage and and the one uh with
like more a more Vigor more but I was I
think yeah I'm seeing like less damage
on them uh cool yeah
yes
so the winner pea you were growing in
Minnesota
are those four cultivars typically grown
there or was that really pushing their
limit of a cold climate that they could
be growing
uh so yeah you mean other really growing
uh right so is it really common for
people to grow winter pea versus a
different crop for like those specific
cultivars in Minnesota or are they more
adapted to say somewhere further south
that still gets cold like Iowa but not
maybe as frigid is yeah so winter pea uh
it's not more common to grow I would say
people usually grow the spring type uh I
think that is the one of the reasons
like we don't have the winter cultivars
that's you can adapt to higher elevation
yet uh but yeah so like we are trying it
mainly for the cover crop purpose yeah
because it's beneficial to have them
instead of putting it fellow or always
just having the cereal Rye there
uh I hope I answered
right thank you
um thank you Margie for that
introduction I really appreciate it
again I'm Savannah Dale from the Vanek
and Gore labs and today I'll be talking
about the work that I've been doing in
the Vanek lab with crispr
um looking at the role of with analytes
and insect interactions
so to just give you an overview first
I'll talk about a little bit of the
background and motivation behind this
project and then we'll talk about the
with natural variation of with analytes
and a couple different species of
physalis next
um I will give a little bit of a brief
background on using crispr cas9 to
produce
um or to disrupt physical insect
resistance and then looking at how we
use the mutants from that process and
insect bioassays to actually look at the
insect resistance phenotypes and then
I'll end with the current work as well
as a summary
so to start out with this list is a
Genus within solar and ACA that contains
over 120 different species and of these
many produce edible and often Delicious
Fruit
um in particular in my work I'm really
interested in two different personal
species the first is physalis gracea
which is also known as ground cherry
which we have on the left on the side
the smaller fruit and then additionally
Fizzles peruviana also known as golden
Berry which is on the right golden Berry
has a lot of economic importance
especially in Colombia and other South
American countries
um and we're really interested in it
because a lot of food companies have
predicted a 40 increase in demand in
this crop in the U.S in the coming years
which is really exciting however
susceptibility to Herbivore damage is
really a large obstacle in the
successful adoption of this crop in the
U.S and this is something this the
species hasn't been improved for insect
resistance and that's what I'm really
interested in in particular This is
highly susceptible to Lima deterophila
which is the three-line potato beetle
um they're pretty cute I think
personally
um but they cause hydrophagus damage so
they chew on Leaf tissue and as both
larvae and adults and the adults lay
their their eggs on the plants and the
larvae hatch out eat some leaves crawl
into the soil where they pupate and then
they'll re-emerge as as adults and
overall this insect is a specialist on
soul and ACA
um one really interesting thing that our
previous work in the lab has shown us is
that physical is much less susceptible
to herbivory by Elda terafila and has a
lot less damage than peruviana so we
really want to understand what the
difference in this resistance phenotype
between these two species is and
um potentially use this knowledge to
improve prove Rihanna in the future
so we hypothesized that specialized
metabolites would be contributing to
this variation in resistance phenotypes
between the two species
and in particular we're really
interested in this group of sterile
chemicals called with analytes and this
is a large group of compounds there are
over 120 that have been identified in
physical species but they are
restricted to only about 13 Genera
um so they're pretty highly specialized
and they have been shown not in faceless
peruviana or Gracia by in other species
to have insect anti-fedent activity
um and another thing that makes them a
really good or a really interesting
Target for us is that they have
chemotherapeutic uses and also
anti-inflammatory activity which means
that they are very beneficial for human
health and have a lot of medicinal value
as well
so moving on
um early in this project before I even
joined the lab
um the lab looked at the metabolite
composition between physical and
physical rubiana and here on the left we
have
um
um a PL SDA plot looking at General
specialized metabolite
makeup of these two different species
and we have two different clusters one
representing Gracia and one representing
peruviana and this just shows that there
is variation in metabolite profiling
additionally from this data we were able
to retrieve a cluster of with anilide
ions from this and able to show that
there was an intensity fold change
between Gracia and prove Jana for these
with red representing with analytes that
are in higher abundance in Russia than
they are in peruviana
so since we've shown that there is this
natural variation what we wanted to do
was break this resistance phenotype and
physical and the way that we did that
was by using crispr cas9 to Target key
genes in the with analyte biosynthetic
pathway we first started out by
targeting this Gene 24 ISO which is the
known committed step in the biosynthetic
pathway in an effort to
um recover mutants that had
um
a different with Ali profile from the
wild type and ideally A reduced with
analyte abundance
and we were able to successfully do that
we were able to recover mutant lines
that had overall reduced with Allied
content these are simple bar plots
looking at relative abundance of with
analytes between the wild type on the
right and the 24 isome mutant lines on
the left and this is just looking at
three with analyte compounds that have
known chemical structures and as you can
see there is a large reduction in with
analyze so from there we actually wanted
to look at the insect herbivory
phenotypes that um we would see with
these mutants when compared to Wild type
and to do this going back to the cute
little three-line potato beetles
um we took entire leaves from both our
mutants and our controls and place them
in Petri dishes and added El datera Fila
beetles to these and we got some really
interesting results
first we found that adults consumed more
Leaf area on the mutants with reduced
with anilides than they did on the wild
type which is what we expected so that
was really exciting to see and then
um we also found that El desperophila
laid more eggs on the mutants when
compared with the wild type so this is
suggesting that these with analytes
potentially have
different mechanisms through the which
they deter or confer insect resistance
um but the problem with this experiment
is that this was using entire leaves so
we couldn't separate it out with
analytes from the other endogenous
specialized metabolites that were
present in the plants and because the
Beetles are specialized on soul and ACA
we expect that they are potentially
partially adapted to consuming with
analytes so moving forward we performed
Leaf painting bioassays
um in which we extracted with analytes
from wild-type physalis gracea and
painted these onto Leaf discs and then
we performed experiments using
trichoplusion e which is the Cabbage
Looper
um
and no choice bio assays and we also
used both a high and a low concentration
of with analytes to see if we could have
a variation in our our results
and we got very very strong results from
the study which was exciting
um we found that the with analyte
treatment did significantly affect
larval survival
and most importantly the with Ali
treatments
significantly reduced larval survival
after 48 Hours
um this is really exciting but I really
wanted to know why were they dying are
they with analytes toxic were they just
not eating the tissue so I looked
further at this information and here in
this bar plot I have separated the data
by each treatment in each of these boxes
and then within each treatment I looked
at the larvae that ate and those that
did not eat and in green we have the
larvae that survived the number of
larvae survived and in Gray the top
Stacks the number of larvae that
perished
um this is pretty striking in and of
itself overall most of the larvae didn't
eat anything on either of the with Ali
treatments whereas about half of the
larvae did consume some Leaf tissue on
the wild type and we I was able to show
that there was a significant difference
in the number of larvae that actually
ate any tissue all between these
treatments and then additionally there
was a significant difference between the
number of larvae that ate and did not
eat but even within the treatments as
well so this was really exciting
um
but there are still more questions to be
asked here uh we still don't know
exactly which with Ally compounds have
the most import or the largest effects
on these resistance phenotypes and
um we also don't know their exact
mechanism still even though we do have a
better understanding
so moving forward and this is what I'm
currently working on is using crispr
cas9 editing again to Target different
genes in the biosynthetic pathway and in
particular here I'm targeting Branch
points of the pathway in an effort to
produce a collection of mutants that
have varying with analyte profiles and
using these mutants I will be doing with
analyte profiling work to be able to
identify different with analytes that
are in higher or lower abundance in
these mutants
when compared with wild type and I will
also be performing more insect bioassays
in particular like the leaf painting
bioassay where I'm really just looking
up with analytes and I will be
correlating this data to be able to
identify which with analytes hopefully
are having the largest impact on the
insect activity
so in summary we have shown that with
Ali profiles do differ between Gracia
and peruviana
um
disrupted 24 isome mutants show
increased uh l-deterophila activity
um through our Leaf painting bioassays
we were able to show that with analytes
do
um
reduce teeny larval survival and reduce
feeding and finally we know that more
research is needed to fully understand
the role of with analytes in this
interaction
and with that I would like to thank all
of the members of my committee Michael
Joyce vanak Jennifer thaler and gaurav
mohi as well as the vanack lab
particularly Nathan Reem who did a lot
of work on this project early on are
collaborators in the thaler lab
especially Julie Davis who helped with a
lot of this work Kristoff duply who did
a lot of the biochemistry in this work
Bennett Schroeder or Bennett Fox from
the Schroeder lab as well as the bti
staff for taking care of my plants
and I'd like to take any questions
yeah Kevin
let's talk Savannah
um so it's surprising in your um with
analytic treatment on Elite Test when
you paint it on that the low with
analyze treatment what you didn't see an
intermediate survival between the high
and the wild type that's a really good
question and moving forward when I
conduct more bioassays I think I would
use a lower concentration with analytes
to see if I could get that intermediate
phenotype
um it was about
twice as much I don't remember exactly
um but I also think that it would be
good because these were not
concentrations that were mimicking wild
type concentrations what we would see
and that's something I would like to do
moving forward yeah great Amy what's
like the typical survival rate you'd
expect to see like it was I felt like
half of them died in the control is that
what you normally see in a bile assay
experiment or no choice experiment like
that yeah thank you so the question is
what is the typical die-off rate for
these insects
um that's a really good question and for
that particular experiment we were
looking at
um trichoplusion knee which is a
generalist on physicalist
um and I would expect that there would
be a reasonable amount of die off I
don't know and that's a really good
question but because it is a generalist
I don't expect it to perform as well as
it would on potential other host plants
begins
are with analytes toxic to humans
um as far as I know no they are used in
a lot of different medicinal
applications which is why they could
potentially be a good reading Target but
I don't
I haven't read anything but I don't know
if you know you're drinking straight
with analyze and high concentrations
what that would do to you but we can eat
these plants we eat the we eat the fruit
and it's fine so
probably not
there is
um one mosque season particular that
lays its the larvae eat the fruit of
this plant
um and it's actually a specialist and is
adapted to eat with analytes and uses
those
um to strengthen its immune system so
that's a really interesting case and I'm
not working with that but there are a
couple people who are
yeah that's a great question do with
analytes have other function in the
plant besides insect resistance
um in short I don't know but these
aren't super well studied as of yet most
of
um the literature on with analyze is
looking at their benefits for human
health
um so not as far as I know but it would
be a really good question
yes
um so there's this difference in
resistance and you you're you're
studying with analyzing with analyzing
in particular but could there be a whole
range of other secondary metabolites
that play a role in the resistance and
if so how would you go about finding out
about that yeah absolutely I so the
question was are there other metabolites
that could be playing a role in insect
resistance I would say definitely yes
um in general we expect that there is
um
the word is escaping me but lots of
metabolites are working together to have
for um co-adaptation purposes with their
insect tests and that sort of thing so
the answer is yes that's why we ended up
doing the bioassays extracting with
analyze specifically to be able to
separate out that information
um and it's a really good question but
that's a huge question because there are
so many different metabolites
um so that's not something I'll be
pursuing but it's a good question
thank you very much
awesome cool well thank you Charlie for
that introduction again my name is Elise
tomachowski and I'm part of the Vanek
and giovannoni labs and today I'm really
excited to share the work that I've been
doing over the past few months to
characterize the incision zone of
bissellus crusaiya
for a bit of background like Savannah I
also work on fistless crusa which is a
fruit crop species in the solanaceae
family that's also part of tomato and
pepper are included
this Epistles Gracia produces small
sweet fruit but has high rates of fruit
obsidian or fruit drop shown in this
picture here hence the name ground
cherry
so this fruit drop problem is a problem
on the large-scale farming side of
things because fruit dropped on the
ground cannot be sold to the market so
you're reducing profits for farmers
therefore I would like to develop
improved germplasm lines with reduced
fruit drop utilizing a crispr cas9 gene
editing technique
I am also using fissile scorsea as a
model species to study the fruit fruit
drop genetics that are underlying it to
control the fruit drop problem
so fruit drop as I've mentioned before
or
told in the literature is called
obsidian so fruit oxygen can be defined
as the shedding of a plant organ along a
boundary of predetermined cells there
are classic examples in nature such as
this Leaf Drop phenotype here from
deciduous trees in North America then
there's also the fruit drop problem
which I am studying evolutionarily this
is really important for plants because
you want to disperse your seeds for the
Next Generation however this is a
problem for farmers and we tend to
select away from fruit drop
so to get us all oriented with the
structures that I will be talking about
for the rest of the presentation I have
a couple of diagrams on the left is an
immature fissile scorsea fruit the fruit
is surrounded by an inflated calyx and
the structure that connects the fruit to
the plant is called the pedestal
zooming in further on the pedestal we
have three regions we have the proximal
pedestal here up top which remains
connected to the plant and is green does
not senest this is unlike the distal
pedestal which remains connected to the
fruit and its senescence upon maturation
the zone that is between the proximal
and the distal pedestal is considered
the obsidian Zone and it is
characterized by small cytoplasmically
dense cells in other species
however in thistles Garcia the cellular
structure of the obsession Zone has not
been investigated previously
therefore I am trying to develop a
protocol to visually characterize the
obsidian Zone cells of fishless per se a
fruit I want to do this to help
understand the differentiation and
development of the obsidian Zone
so now I will go into two different
methods that I've used to image my
obsidian Zone cells
the first was embedding my pedestals in
a compound called optimal cutting
temperature compound or OCT for short
this is a pedestalt or fissile scrusaya
pedestal on the left at 25 days post and
thesis for reference the pedestal will
detach around 30 days post-strand thesis
so it is about five days out from
detaching on the left is where the fruit
would be connected to the pedestal and
on the right is where it would be
connected to the plant
on the macroscopic scale this is what
this pedestal looks like and you can see
that senescence has started to occur via
the yellowing and there is a very
distinct obsidian Zone that can be seen
by the naked eye however on the
microscopic level the only indications
of an incision zone are these two zones
of Separation again what I wanted to say
is that the obsidian Zone cells in other
species like tomato have zones of
smaller cells that are very easily
distinguishable from the surrounding
parenchyma cells shown in tomato here by
the Red Box
this is not what I am seeing in my
fistless pedestal via the oct and what I
think is going on is that these sections
that I took using OCT were quite thick
whereas the protocol here was on the
right for the Tomato was using a
paraffin embedded protocol therefore I
wanted to optimize a paraffin embedded
protocol for my fistulous pedestals
after a lot of trial and error I was
able to do so and I would like to get us
oriented again so on the left is where
it would be connected to the plant this
time and on the right is where it would
connect to the fruit this dark Zone here
is just an artifact from sectioning
these pedestals not laying flat on the
side so that is not the obsession Zone
in fact I think that the obsidian zone
is indicated here by the Red Arrows
these cells are much smaller than the
parenchyma cells surrounding them on
either side
you can also see that the obsession Zone
cells create a concave Arc where you can
imagine that the distal pedestal will
detach from the proximal pedestal on the
left
I then wanted to zoom in further on
these obsidian Zone cells to look at any
cellular structure of them and what was
going on further
so to zoom in again you can notice the
obsidian Zone cells marked here by the
bracket they're much smaller than the
parenchyma cells that surround them
either on the left or the right what
else I noticed is that this cell wall
seemed to be degraded of these incision
Zone cells there's also higher
intracellular space so what this
indicates to me is that cell separation
has started to occur however this
pedestal here is 21 days post anthesis
or about three weeks and the one that I
showed previously was 25. so I would
expect that about four days later I
would see the separation be more
prominent
what I've been showing currently are
what are called radial sections so what
I'm doing is splitting the pedestal down
the middle and or the radius and you are
getting indications of the vasculature
which is on the previous slide however I
wanted to see what the obsidian Zone
looked like on a more tangential section
that's closer to the outside of the
pedestal
so I was able to do so and again in this
picture I'm not seeing any indications
of the vasculature so I think that the
pedestal is closer to the outside or the
suction is closer to the outside of the
pedestal in this case I see that the
obsidian Zone cells span from the top to
the bottom
so with this these last two sections I
was able to think about how the
subcision zone is structured in the
pedestal and what I'm thinking is that
the obsession Zone creates this circular
disc about 10 cell layers wide that
encompasses the vasculature in this case
it would be this blue tube going through
the pedestal
this however is in stark contrast with
tomato pedestals so tomato paste
pedestals and this one is a breaker it
was taken from a breaker fruit
if the obsession Zone spans from the top
to the bottom and it also spans across
the vasculature here in the middle so
what this indicates to me is that
obsidian Zone structures vary across the
plant kingdom
lastly I want to indicate that the
excision Zone cells seem to
differentiate at a specific time point
so what you were seeing before were
about three week old pedestals and what
I'm showing now is a seven day post
anthesis pedestal and I'm not seeing
that classic Obsession Zone cells
they're not differentiating to be
smaller
there might be some differentiation
towards the bottom especially but again
it's not spanning from the bottom
towards the vasculature so I'm trying to
understand why this is
which brings me to my next steps I want
to do a Time series using wild type
fistles for sale and tomato pedestals to
understand at what point these Obsession
Zone cells are differentiating I expect
them to be at any point between 7 and 20
days both stand these lists now that I
have been able to optimize a paraffin
embedded protocol and have high
resolution of my obsidian Zone cells I
will then use these for my crispr
mutants where I have two different
sections of the crisper lines that I'm
taking forward the first are Obsession
Zone development mutant lines and in
this one where I what I expect on the
microscopic level is that the incision
Zone cells never differentiate I don't
see an obsidian Zone in these pedestals
however on my other lines that are
targeting self-superation genes what I
expect to happen is that there isn't an
obsidian zone differentiating so I see
small cells but the cell separation that
I zoomed in on earlier in the
presentation will either not happen or
it will be delayed
so in summary I have generated the first
images of the fistless Crusade obsidian
Zone using an optimized paraffin
embedded protocol
it looks to me as though the obsidian
Zone does not span across the
vasculature as it does in tomato and it
also seems to differentiate at a
specific time point
and my future work is to look at my
crispr mutants that I have generated
using this optimized paraffin embedded
protocol
with that I would like to acknowledge
all of my committee members Joyce fanek
Jim giovannoni and Adrian Roeder as well
as all the members of the van Eck lab
specifically Savannah Dale and Victoria
swiler who was an Ru student this summer
with me
I would also like to thank all the
members of the giovannoni lab
specifically Julia and Eamon for all of
their help and a very large thank you to
Sergey from Maria Harrison's lab in at
bti for all of his help with optimizing
the paraffin protocol lastly I would
also like to thank the bti greenhouse
staff they're great and help maintain
all of my plans
and with that I will take any questions
yes
so when you prepare tomatoes
uh right now I'm looking at cultivated
studies one thing I want to do is use
one of the more uh on or not
domesticated versions so to see if the
subcision zone is spans across the
vasculature as well
um similar questions do you think that
the exhibitions themselves will
eventually cut through the next section
of like you know like if you think it's
a different time Point yeah comparison
versus difference that's perfect I I
have that question and I think I'm not
sure what the answer is going to be so
the task to me to separate the
vasculature seems huge I'm not sure
exactly how that happens yet maybe the
cells do expand and crush the xylem and
phloem but one problem that I'm having
is that these pedestals when they are
detached are almost about to detach you
can breathe and they fall off so trying
to embed something like that around 25
days or later is very difficult so if I
can figure that out I'll give you great
images but hopefully I can see that it
does span across or it doesn't that's
what I'll be under trying to understand
do other fissile species have the same
fruit
no so it actually varies across the uh
fisslist species you have golden Berry
which Savannah talked about and it
doesn't have an obsession Zone at all so
it doesn't drop I think that's also
probably why these golden Berry are
probably going to be in the market
faster than ground cherry but maybe I'll
catch that up with them so we'll see
okay yeah are you doing so you have uh
crispr line so you've been thinking
about like the genetic cause of it are
you doing any sort of mapping or
comparing across other physical species
I think that's a whole other PhD project
I totally wanted to but that would take
me another PhD projects I don't have
time to that but yeah with golden Berry
not having an obsession Zone there must
be genetics behind this on why fistulous
grassea does but peruviana does not so
yes you're on the right I also thought
of that
okay Matthew
um have you or do you see similarities
yeah I so I'm not shown here any on any
of my sides but with tomato you do have
a lot of ethylene released towards
ripening I was able to measure that and
I am seeing ethylene being released in
my Epistles per sea so I've also applied
these exogenous hormones as well which
I'm not including in these slides and
they are responding similar to exogenous
either ethylene which was increasing
Obsession or it's delaying Obsession
when I applied Ox so they seem to be
related to tomato
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu